Some movies are so iconic that it’s hard
to imagine what cinema would be like if they
never existed.
The legacies left in their wake can be seen
across genres, and form the basis of more
stories than we realize.
It is thanks to the persistence and hard work
of these pioneering crews that some of our
favorite movies were ever finished.
These are 10 Famous Movies That Almost Didn’t
Get Made (For Shocking Reasons).
Star Wars
When George Lucas set out to tell the story
of a galaxy far, far away, it seems the whole
universe united against him.
The director had an impossible time finding
a studio to fund 1977’s Star Wars.
And when he did, they didn’t exactly give
him enough money.
The actors weren’t into it either, and thought
the movie was going to be for kids.
Plus, huge storms on set in Tunisia not only
wrecked a ton of the equipment, it also delayed
production.
Somehow though, Lucas got it done.
It’s one of the most beloved franchises
of all time, and he’s got the legion of
fans to prove it.
Jaws
Known as one of the most frightening movies
of all time, Steven Spielberg’s Jaws has
been terrifying audiences since it was released
in 1975.
The story of a man-eating Great White shark
stalking the beaches of Amity Island is a
hard one to forget, especially when swimming
alone.
But for the crew members, the production is
memorable for it’s off-screen scares.
The three animatronic sharks built for the
shoot often sank, had to be repainted daily,
and had to be rebuilt every week because of
the saltwater.
Plus, thanks to a stipulation in the contract,
Martha’s Vineyard agreed to let the crew
film there, but the set decorators had to
put up and tear down the props every day.
Mad Max: Fury Road
What started out as a drawing snowballed into
a two hour, high octane offering from director
George Miller.
Sidelined due to flooding, skyrocketing insurance
rates, and shipping delays in the post-911
climate, Mad Max: Fury Road was ten years
in the making.
Never one to sit idle for too long, Miller
used his time to consult with experts and
develop his vision.
The delays in production turned out to be
kind of a blessing.
The film’s every element is accounted for,
and designed to a T. Plus, the stunt team
had the opportunity to practice their moves
so much, that they were able to execute them
without CGI.
Blade Runner
Some of the most amazing worlds presented
on screen were first conceived in books.
And any director who takes on the challenge
of merging their vision with the existing
work of an author has their work cut out for
them.
1982’s Blade Runner was based on the book
Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep? by Philip
K. Dick.
And when he saw what the studio wanted to
do with it, he was unimpressed.
Apparently he wasn’t the only one.
The film’s director Ridley Scott needed
some convincing too, and had already refused
the job once.
It even had it’s budget pulled, but somehow
the movie managed to get made.
Apocalypse Now
According to Murphy’s law anything that
can go wrong, will go wrong.
And if you ever doubted that sentiment, just
take a look at the filming of 1979’s Apocalypse
Now.
Marlon Brando, a principal cast member, returned
from a hiatus in filming looking unrecognizable
and didn’t know any of his lines.
Martin Sheen suffered a heart attack.
And everyone on the crew was constantly getting
sick.
Even if you remove the physical ailments,
the production was still subject to the very
real risks of shooting in nature.
The sets were annihilated by a typhoon.
The native wildlife posed a constant threat.
And the filming went way over schedule.
The Wizard of Oz
In every conversation about Hollywood classics,
film buffs always pay homage to 1939’s The
Wizard of Oz, with some even speculating that
it’s the most watched movie in history.
Good thing, too, since the cast went through
hell to get it made.
The adorable little Toto was hard to keep
on cue, and had to be replaced after an injury.
Two of the actors even had to be hospitalized
because of their costumes.
The original actor signed on to play the Tin
Man almost died when the aluminum dust in
his makeup coated his lungs and caused an
allergic reaction.
And Margaret Hamilton, a.k.a The Wicked Witch
of the West, was burned by the copper in her
face paint after getting trapped on a fiery
set piece.
World War Z
Lately there’s been a lot of talk about
studios meddling with movies after shooting
has already wrapped, with Fantastic Four and
Suicide Squad leading the conversation.
But a few years earlier, a different property
was at the forefront: World War Z.
Although its technically an adaptation of
the Max Brooks novel, the similarities begin
and end with it’s title.
After shooting had already wrapped, the studio
ordered reshoots and changed the ending.
They even brought in different writers to
do it.
Just when it seemed things couldn’t get
worse, Brad Pitt would no longer acknowledge
director Marc Forster in person, and spoke
through a proxy.
Jurassic Park
Jurassic Park has been roaring into our living
rooms since it’s release in 1993.
It has a great story, pioneering special effects
that still meet today’s standard, and a
handful of heart-stopping moments.
But during filming, director Steven Spielberg
had a few heart-stopping moments of his own.
The robotic T-rex weighed over twelve thousand
pounds.
And if Spielberg learned anything from Jaws,
it should have been that animatronics and
water do not go well together.
After a few days in the rain, the damage began
to manifest in a terrifying way: by coming
alive and roaring uncontrollably.
Titanic
James Cameron is responsible for some of the
most epic movies of all time.
The director has a knack for turning his personal
passions into big screen spectaculars.
Enamored with underwater exploration, Cameron
merged his interest with the story of the
ill-fated voyage of the Titanic.
As we’ve mentioned before, productions that
use a lot of water tend to hit more snags,
and this one is no exception.
Members of the stunt team were injured, the
shoot went over its schedule and its budget.
The director was a force all his own, and
reportedly blew his top more than once.
Apparently someone even spiked the catering
with PCP in protest.
Deadpool
Hollywood presents itself as all glitz and
glam, but the behind the scenes challenges
of getting a movie made can sometimes be,
well, boring.
Take Deadpool for example.
Despite the character’s insanely loyal fanbase
and box office potential, it took way longer
than it should have for the merc with a mouth
to get a proper movie.
Why?
Because the project kept changing hands.
Ryan Reynolds was always on board to play
the character, and even got to in X-Men Origins:
Wolverine.
But everyone knew Wade Wilson deserved better,
and in 2016, patience paid off and fans got
what they were waiting for.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other movies that almost didn't
get made?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more of our videos.